hey this is a very strange series of
events um
earlier in the day on um monday
uh jordan peterson attacked me
he subsequently went on to call a woman
ugly and then announced he's quitting
twitter because it's all gotten too out
of control he's told his staff to change
his password and not give him access to
it however multiple tweets continue to
be posted after that presumably by his
staff so let's go kind of like point by
point here okay so the first thing that
happened is that jordan peterson posted
about my video criticizing him jordan
peterson recently gave a talk during
which he wept because young people are
being told that there's a climate crisis
and jordan peterson didn't like my video
and he tweeted at me he attacked me and
he said quote i was speaking of the
unacceptable demoralization of young
people i've seen it all over the world
and this cynical dismissal is all you
can muster how utterly pathetic
deepakman how do you think endless
apocalyptic catastrophizing affects
children he then went on
uh to send an additional tweet he sent a
second tweet very quickly
where he said and congratulations on
capturing an audience motivated to spew
so consistently the corrosive and
personal vitriol that makes up the
comments on this video clip a likely
epitaph for you eaten by his own
children so he's really really really
not happy with me
now as a reminder the video he's
referring to is jordan peterson weeps
over climate activism and in that video
i pointed out
we shouldn't be weeping
that it's upsetting to kids to learn
about what we're doing to the planet we
should be weeping over the fact that
we're destroying the planet and jordan
peterson's perspective is when you tell
children and young people
all of these terrible things that are
going on it's demoralizing to them it's
horrible and he wept he wept he wept
over it and my point was we have to be
honest with people and if we're bringing
up a new generation who is number one
going to deal with the consequences of
climate change and number two be in a
position hopefully to deal with it we
can't lie to them we can't hide from
them that this is what's happening on
this planet and anyway he didn't like it
he thinks it's demoralizing to tell them
that so jordan peterson flipping out on
me
moments later
he um went after the physical appearance
of a woman
um there is this woman i actually
haven't been following this story but i
guess the sports illustrated swimsuit
issue this year
wanted to feature
different body types and there's a
heavier woman who was featured and
jordan peterson after attacking me on
twitter tweeted about this woman sorry
not beautiful and no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is going to
change that so kind of a weird thing for
jordan peterson to be tweeting about
and then not too long after that jordan
peterson announced that he is indeed
leaving twitter
uh it's gotten to be too much for him
saying quote so i told my staff to
change my password to keep me from
temptation and them departing once again
if i have something to say i'll write an
article or make a video if the issue is
not important enough to justify that
then perhaps it would be best to just
let it go
very very unstable incredibly unstable
individual and uh honestly i don't even
i mean listen jordan peterson
we've talked for a while about how he
seems unwell we've talked for a while
about how a lot of his followers seem to
be sort of like bamboozled and fall into
a cult of personality we've said a lot
of things about jordan peterson i'm
actually with him
significant use of twitter isn't that
healthy we know that and for some people
in particular it's really not healthy i
know people personally who because of
their personalities
uh addictive personalities and and sort
of uh
the the endless need to keep scrolling
i see how corrosive it is to their um uh
mental state their emotional state to be
on social media they just shouldn't be
on it and it really seems like for
jordan peterson it's very bad to be on
social media so i actually respect him
for getting off of twitter
it's not clear he's really off because
the tweets keep coming but i guess it's
his staff that are sending the tweets
but what a 24 hours flipping out on me
calling a woman ugly and then saying
it's gotten bad and i'm quitting so we
wish him the best
i think it is better for him
not to be on twitter
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
that specializes in documentaries my
audience can get a curiosity stream
subscription for only about a dollar a
month at curiositystream.com
pacman we all know netflix then hulu
they have some documentaries but
curiosity stream has a way better
selection in every category i'm always
finding documentaries on curiosity
stream i can't find anywhere else i just
watched electing lincoln which is a
three-part series about what led to the
election of abraham lincoln fascinating
absolutely fascinating curiosity stream
has an app for all of your devices i've
always got it going on the tv or i can
do put it on my tablet when i travel
with curiosity stream i can explore a
new topic i never knew i'd be interested
in or
zone out with a great nature documentary
whatever you're looking for it's there
and you can get curiosity stream for
just 14.99 a year that's less than two
bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below